um find a friend you love and uh you
know one of those people who if you
called them at three o'clock in the
morning you know they'd take your call
and you would take theirs
um
don't do this with a spouse don't do
this with a sibling
don't do this with a boyfriend or
girlfriend those relationships are too
close
but find a best friend and ask them the
simple question
why are we friends
and they're going to look at you like
you're crazy because it's very hard for
the human brain to put our feelings into
words because the part of the brain that
controls our feelings doesn't control
language this is why we use metaphors
and analogies and why we struggle to
tell people how we actually feel it's
because it's a different part of the
brain and so they're going to look at
you and be like
i don't know
why are you asking me this and you say
come on i know you've been there for me
uh my whole life
and then you actually stop asking the
question why ironically you actually ask
the question what you say come on what
specifically is it about me that i know
you'd be there for me no matter what and
they're going to hem and hog because
it's hard to put into words don't help
them don't let anybody else help them
and they're going to start describing
you i don't know you're funny you're
smart you're
honest you've always been there for me
you go good you play devil's advocate
good that's the definition of a friend
what specifically is it about me that
i'd know you you'd be there for me no
matter what and again they'll hemanha
and some will get through this quickly
and some will get through it slowly and
it'll be a struggle and you have to
continue to play
devil's advocate good that's the
definition of a close friend what
specifically is about me and eventually
they'll give up
eventually they'll stop
describing you and they'll start
describing themselves like my friend
said to me simon i don't know all i know
is that i can sit in a room with you i
don't even have to talk to you and i
feel inspired and i got goosebumps in
fact i'm getting them right now
they will put into words the value you
have in their life and you will have the
emotional reaction you'll either well up
with tears or you will get goosebumps
this puts you in the ballpark this is
where your y lives and if you do this
with multiple friends they will say the
same kind of thing ins in fact sometimes
they'll say the same exact thing because
your why is the thing you give to the
world and amongst your closest and best
friends it is the space you fill in
their lives so that's a fun little way
you can find your why
the simple answer is no
a y is the sum total of who you are it
is the sum total of of the experiences
you had when you were a kid the the way
you were raised what you got from your
parents your family your friends um
that made you who you are
um
you can change
uh the way you navigate the world you
can change what you do
but you can't change who you are
um
our lives offer us opportunity to live
in balance with who we are or not like
if we start doing things that are
counted who we are our friends say to us
it's like i don't know who you are
anymore right um and that is what your
why is your why is the fundamental core
of what inspires you it is the spark
that that drives you um and our whys are
fully formed probably by our mid to late
teens the early the youngest uh y
discovery i've ever done was a 16 year
old um and that's it so no a why does
not change and uh uh if anything crisis
reveals it to us but it doesn't change
it
i don't
care what someone's motivation is
my only rule is they have to want it
that
it should never be thrust upon them so i
will never
coerce push convince or pressure someone
to learn their why
um they have to decide they want it it's
like the old joke um how many
psychiatrists does it take to change a
light bulb
one but the light bulb has to really
want to change
um
it's the same thing like i will help my
friends like my friends
all know that if they ask me to help
them find their why the answer will
always be yes
but they have to ask
um they have to ask
um
it's the same thing so i you know
i want someone ideal ideally and
philosophically to to do it
you know for for inspirational reasons
but if if they're going through a hard
period or a dark period uh or there's
fear then i you know if this is a tool
that helps
then
and then maybe i don't care what the
what the motivation is maybe i don't
care if it's for inspirational reasons
or maybe i could argue that it's all
inspirational if you're trying to come
out of darkness to find light that's
pretty damn inspiring